it sort of changed with
um uh the idea when
when stephen hawking started talking
about black holes and black holes
um started becoming maybe were becoming
to be more
seriously considered and
what uh you know a black hole is
something where basically
you know everything it's so strong the
gravitational force is so strong
that everything that comes you know too
close to it basically gets sucked in
nothing can get out not even light can
get out that's why it's called black
okay so there's another example of
something you can't really see but we
can see the
effects of it and we now know that
there's black holes
possibly at the center of every galaxy
anyways
the the the the paradox
of the black hole were that
um it seems that anything you threw in
um would be lost in terms of the
information
hawking famously showed that in fact
black holes can leak that um that
that you know because of quantum
mechanics at the edge
things can leak out but it's just
a very diffuse radiation so it doesn't
reflect anything that went in there so
no matter what
goes in there you know whether you throw
an elephant in there or a book or
anything like that
what comes out is all the same
and so information has been lost we've
lost the information
about what went in there what do you
mean what comes
out is all the same um think of it as
radiation
so you know okay whatever you know uh
you know
more concretely you know if a star
a certain star goes in certain stars
fall into a black hole
other planets things fall into it what
comes out
is just a certain radiation there's
nothing
that tells you what went into forming
the black hole
okay does that make sense or kind of
losing me
okay well there's nothing you know it's
just it's just like
you know uh different things can fall in
different planets
right but what comes out is just
light you know or heat okay so it's it
doesn't
there's nothing we can't get we can't
learn anything
about what went into the black hole by
what comes out
so there's information lost the
information about what the thing was
that went in
is not what comes out so do things are
you saying things actually
are ejected out of black holes at a
different
position like it's somewhere else no not
in somewhere else that comes out
you know it radiates so we know black
holes we can see
that there's radiation coming out very
very low level radiation
okay okay which was initially thought
not to be possible it didn't seem like
radiation is light
[Music]
it didn't seem like anything could come
out
um we know things do come out um
but what comes out isn't related to what
went in
um and it seems like so the idea was it
seemed like information was lost that
things fall into the black hole
it seemed like that that we lose
information and now
and it's still a very hot topic but it
seems but
and one of the things businesses have
had to do is really go back to
um information theory and think about
information carefully to try and
understand it and so
it has you know information theory has
has become very important in cosmology
um in terms of its understanding so
again
um you know there are people that have
claimed that
um information is actually more
fundamental than
a lot of you know other concepts in
physics so famously
there's a physicist named john wheeler
who basically
kip thorne i think was was wheeler
student
and so kip thorne from you know
interstellar right
so he worked with wheeler they wrote a
famous
book on gravitation and um
wheeler very much believed that
um in the end information was everything
he he famously coined
the the phrase it's from bits that he
felt that
everything was ultimately going to have
to be looked at from the terms of
information so
um you know that's still i don't think
that's been
borne out but it's still it's still
something that people talk about is
information
is that the fundamental way we should
look at the world in terms of
information
not just information and communication
but just is that the way we
do we need to come up with a theory of
the universe based on just on
information so
it's had a lot of applications and um
well it's interesting
they do go hand in hand with the
information that you get from combining
particles with the lhc i mean it
nothing means anything unless you have
those ones and zeros that are
transmitted to those hundreds of
thousands of computers
right right yes well that yeah that is
the way we analyze it for sure and
that's
you know i mean again cern you know um
uh you know was at the forefront of how
do we
um how do we handle
so much information how can we compress
it um
you know one of the interesting things
is right now is um
you know even with everything that cern
has done
the amount of information that we're
having to deal with not only at cern
which is also expanding but everywhere
else is is
you know a lot of people believe
uh really going to exceed our capability
of uh advancing in terms of the
classical way we construct computers
in terms of you know our chips our
semiconductor chips and things like that
and so
you know one of the what chips
semiconductors you know the
silicon ships the things that are in you
know our computers now
right so so we've gotten used to these
things
getting faster and more powerful right
that every
every couple of years there's new
generations this was famously
um canonized in something called moore's
law
and moore's law was this observation
that um moore observed
that it seemed like our abilities to
make smaller and smaller
and denser chips of semiconductors
you know every year and a half would
double our capacity
and that has been true has been true for
many many
years and we had taken you know we we
have you know
benefited from it as our devices get
smaller and faster and things like that
but
we are approaching uh physical limits
you know we're
you know we're at the atomic level
almost and so
uh and we're generating more and more
data and especially like in artificial
intelligence and things like that with
these
you know so-called machine learning uh
devices that are becoming so you know
more and more
evident it requires huge amounts of data
and so um one of the things people are
investigating is the idea of can we make
a quantum computer a computer that
operates at the quantum level and so
ibm has now formed a consortium with a
number of people including cern
and so i talked to some of my friends at
cern and they're
they're very concerned about the
fact that no pun intended um
about the uh ability to deal with all
this and that
you know uh are they gonna need
you know what what is the future of
computing that's gonna allow them to
deal with all
of this so again information it's
information information information
that's our
that's our